Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hato sanma-sambodhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So we're going to look at this Kalama Sutta, which is probably amongst Westerners who get converted, one of these very well-known discourses.
It's probably more widely known than that.
Basically, it's really about the right to ask questions that Buddhism doesn't come at you with, thou shalt believe.
And what happens is, the opening scene, the Buddha arrives at a place called Kesaputta, where he meets these Kalamas, and they're in a state of confusion.
There are some monks and Brahmins, Venerable Sir, who visit Kesaputta.
They expound and explain only their own doctrines, and the doctrines of others they despise, revile, and pull to pieces.
So it's a case of I'm right, nobody else is wrong.
So the Kalamas say, Venerable Sir, there is doubt, there is uncertainty in us concerning them.
Which of these reverend monks and Brahmins spoke the truth and which falsehood?
Okay.
So what we discovered, of course, is that they've got this existential terror of the age, which was what will happen when I die and what my rebirth will be.
And just as an aside, the Greeks and Romans, the ancient world, of course, were sort of afraid of fate, by which they meant what these capricious gods felt like doing.
And they had no power over it.
And
The horror was to end up in Hades, where when you hear descriptions of it, it's a bit like advanced dementia, where you lose your identity.
You're just wandering around aimless in this dark place.
And if you get to see the Odyssey, he sort of has a stab at it.
In the medieval ages, of course, it was the sheer existential fear of going to hell.
And that's when the Roman Catholic Church came up with the idea of purgatory, so that only those who committed really bad mortal sins went to hell.
The others could spend their time in a place where they were purified and then go to heaven.
And these days, of course, for people who are scientific materialists,
And it's the abyss, what Nietzsche called the abyss, like death is moving into nothingness.
And when Nietzsche touched upon that, he called it the abyss.
So here we have it, this particular time, it was this whole rebirth thing.
And there were people at the time who were materialists who said, well, no, you know, when your life ends, that's the end of it.
You don't have to worry about what happens afterwards.
So now the Kalama wants to know the truth and he doesn't fall into the error of these other teachers of telling them what he teaches and how everybody else is completely deluded.
So he starts by trying to lead them out of that confusion to give them some guidelines
And he offers this method of freedom to investigate.
So he makes this what's considered a very famous statement.
It is proper for you Kalamas to doubt, to be uncertain.
Uncertainty has arisen in you about what is doubtful.
Come Kalamas, do not go upon what has been acquired by repeated hearing.
And if you think of Trump and the way he keeps repeating his lie until a lot of people believe him.
Nor upon tradition, nor upon rumour, nor upon the scriptures, because just something's written down in some holy scripture doesn't mean it's true.
Nor upon surmise, you know, to form an opinion or guess without really having the evidence and then believing it.
Nor upon an axiom.
So something that's universally accepted doesn't mean it's true.
Nor upon a bias towards a notion that has been pondered over.
And so these days we get these information silos.
Not upon another seeming ability, you know, their teaching ability and being drawn into that.
If he can teach so well, he must be talking the truth.
Nor upon the consideration, this monk is our teacher.
kalamas when so so you don't you don't believe it just because your teacher said it but when you yourselves know these things are immoral these things are blameable these things are censured by the wise undertaken and observed these lead to harm and ill when you know that by your own personal experience then he says abandon them so he's rejecting the idea of blind belief
Now, he's not saying that you can decide what you want to believe.
It's not a freedom to believe what you want as if the spiritual life was a sort of smorgasbord and you just choose little bits that you like.
And that often happens to Westerners, doesn't it?
We can see the process of meditation, we like that, but rebirth, well, that's just an idea.
The test, of course, is to do with ethics.
So there's a connection here with rebirth and ethics.
So he doesn't leave them entirely to their own resources.
He says, Kalamas, when you yourselves know these things are bad, these things are blameable, these things are censured by the wise, undertaken and observed, these things lead to harm and ill, then abandon them.
So that's a direct sort of connection with what a person might feel to be unskillful.
And then he begins this sort of Socratic method of questions and answers.
So what do you think, Kalamas?
Does greed manifest in someone for their benefit or for their harm?
For their harm, Venerable Sir.
Kalamas, being given to greed and being overwhelmed and vanquished mentally by greed, such a person takes life, steals, commits adultery and tells lies.
They also prompt others to do likewise.
Will that not eventually be harmful and damaging to them?
Yes, Venerable Sir.
And of course, he repeats that with hatred and delusion.
And then he says, so he's continuing this process of questioning them.
And in a sense, he's teaching them as I think Socrates had wanted to do.
So then he continues this.
And I think this is the way that we understand Socrates to have wanted people to...
to find a way in which they can question themselves.
So what do you think, Kalamas?
Are these things good or bad?
Bad, Venerable Sir.
Blameable or not blameable?
Blameable, Venerable Sir.
Censured and praised by the wise?
Censured, Venerable Sir.
Undertaken and observed, do these things lead to harm or ill?
Or how does it strike you?
So what do you think?
And they say, well, undertaken and observed, these things lead to harm and ill. That's very clear to us.
And then, of course, he does the opposite.
What do you think, Kalamas?
Does absence of greed manifest in someone for their benefit and harm?
For their benefit, venerable sir, and so on.
So the question, of course, is how do we know that something is genuinely true, wise or beneficial?
So remember that we are prone to confirmation bias, you know, just listening and talking to people who agree with us and always self-affirming our own beliefs.
So the Buddha talks about the three ingredients that go into freezing us into a sort of wrong place.
So that's the initial wrong understanding, the wrong view, our emotional commitment to it.
And of course, most entrapping is a sense of identity.
So as soon as you say, I am a...
And whatever that finishes with, I am a Buddhist, then you're trapped, as it were, into that.
Now, of course, some entrapments can be skillful, but he's particularly interested in entrapments that are not.
So in the Kalama Sutta, he's giving them permission to think for themselves.
Now, having done that,
He now gives them the exercise in which they can establish, we can say, a good mind, a good heart.
And that, of course, is the practice of metta.
the disciples of the noble ones kalamas who in this way is devoid of coveting devoid of ill-will undiluted clearly comprehending and mindful dwells pervading one quarter with the thought of love likewise the second likewise the third likewise the fourth
So above, below and across, he dwells, encompassing all sentient beings everywhere in the entire cosmos with the abundant, exalted, boundless thought of love that is free of hatred and malice.
And he does the same for compassion, joy and equanimity.
And here, of course, he's giving them an exercise which, in terms of rebirth, would, you know, angle them towards the happy realms.
So now he offers these four consolations or assurances, having understood what the central concern of the Kalamas were, which was about rebirth and its connection to your karma.
Supposing there is a hereafter and there is a fruit result of deeds done well and ill.
then it is possible that at the dissolution of the body after death, I shall arise in the heavenly world, which is possessed of the state of bliss.
So that's your first consolation if you take his arguments.
But suppose, he says, there is no hereafter, and there is no fruit, no result of deeds done well or ill.
Yet, in this world, here and now, free from hatred, free from malice, safe and sound,
I keep myself.
So this is the second consolation.
So whether there is or not, it's better to live this way.
Suppose evil results befall an evildoer.
I, however, don't think of doing harm to anyone.
Then how can ill results affect me, who has not harmed anyone?
You will find this as your third consolation.
assurance after his teachings and the final one is supposing evil results do not befall an evildoer then i see myself purified in any case so the teaching here the basic line is that the inner happiness of moral integrity surpasses anything which is momentary superficial pleasure
And this, of course, really sort of settles the Kalamas.
Now, he's given them a way of investigating what they've been told.
And he's given them this leeway to decide for themselves whether there is karmic results and whether there is a rebirth or not.
And this seems to have inspired the Kalamas so much that they took the Buddha as their teacher.
So here we have this lovely discourse, which, you know, he enters into this confusion, into these people who are confused.
His intention is to help them out of the confusion, not to convince them of he's right and everybody else is wrong.
So he seems to have that ability to see where you are and to take you from that place to a deeper understanding.
I mean, he's a great teacher.
and he offers them this freedom to inquire he then gives them ethics as the first criterion of truth and recognizing bias and distorted judgment so he's addressing their problems around karma and rebirth and he does this especially through these four assurances and of course he's given them this matter this brahma laharas which will lift their heart
And when he sees that they now see him as perhaps their teacher, you can presume that either later in the day, because perhaps he arrived in the morning and now he's been offered some food and he takes a rest.
The siesta.
Yeah.
And then he comes back.
And then, of course, seeing that these people have been, shall we say, affected by his teaching, he probably hits them with the Four Noble Truths.
And if he doesn't think they're ready, then he'll come back and visit them at a later date.
So here we have a lovely story which tells us a lot about the Buddha and just his remarkable ability to teach people.
Very good.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance, that they have not caused confusion, and that by your devotion to investigating the truth and making sure that you practice, you will arrive at that wonderful place, free of suffering, nibbana, sooner rather than later.